[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de venir parler devant vous et
pour me préparer j'ai re visionner les
discours célèbre des grandes
personnalités que j'admire
et tous ont la même recette miracle pour
attirer l'attention de l'auditoire
votre attention
parler de leur enfance riche en
rebondissements plus spectaculaires les
uns que les autres
le problème c'est que mon enfance est
probablement la plus banal et ordinaire
que vous puissiez imaginer
j'ai eu une enfance heureuse entre
bordeaux et un petit village au nord des
landes qui s'appelle sanguine et
je n'ai pas spécialement d'actes de
bravoure à mon actif ou d'exploit sous
la main que je pourrai comme ça vous
raconter
bref un gamin sans histoires
pour vous dire à quel point mon enfance
n'a vraiment rien spectaculaire le plus
grand traumatisme de mes jeunes années
aussi loin que je m'en souvienne c'est
la mort darchy
mon chien
quant à free est mort je devais avoir 7
ou 8 ans et je me suis fait une promesse
plus jamais de chiens plus jamais
alors quand deux ou trois ans plus tard
ma mère en a voulu à nouveau j'ai entamé
une véritable insurrection familiale
pour l'en empêcher
et c'est là que pour la première fois la
politique est entré dans ma vie
il se trouve qu'au même moment j'étais
tombé par hasard dans la bibliothèque de
mon école sur un livre de dix ou quinze
pages vous savez ces petits livres pour
enfants avec plus d'image que de textes
qui s'appelait la politique pour les
jeunes
et à la fin de ce petit livre il y avait
un manuel pratique pour organiser une
élection
j'ai trouvé ça fascinant et ni une ni
deux j'ai découpé des petits bouts de
papier créé une urne en carton et le
soir même après dîner j'ai organisé un
vote référendum même avec toute ma
famille sur un sujet de la plus haute
importance
faut-il adopter un nouveau chien
chacun a voté j'ai mené campagne tambour
battant et à mon grand désespoir malgré
tous mes efforts le pour l'a emporté et
on a eu un nouveau chien
je venais de faire l'expérience de la
démocratie
et de perdre lamentablement il faut bien
le reconnaître
la première élection de ma vie
malgré cet échec retentissant trop tard
j'ai été contaminé
contaminée par le seul virus que je vous
souhaite à chacun d'attraper le virus de
l'engagement
arrivé au collège je me suis fait lire
délégués de classe plus déléguer
l'établissement
cette nouvelle expérience de la
politique entre guillemets moine a
montré toutes ses potentialités
défendre des idées s'impliquer pour les
autres agir
j'en ai aussi entrevue les limites comme
ce voyage à aqualand que j'ai promis à
toute ma classe de troisième et que le
directeur du collège évidemment n'a
jamais voulu financer
d'autres expériences plus ou moins
anodine ont progressivement éveillé mon
désir de me rendre utile ou en tout cas
d'essayer
comme cette première collecte à la
banque alimentaire dans un supermarché
de bordeaux à 14 ans où ce stage
quelques temps plus tard comme vendeur
bénévoles dans un magasin emmaüs
ou même bien avant tout cela quand je
n'avais encore que sept ans cette lettre
que j'ai envoyée au premier ministre
lettres probablement truffé de fautes
d'orthographe dans laquelle je lui
soumettaient des idées originales pour
rendre mes cours un peu moins ennuyeux
et je vous laisse imaginer ma tête quand
quelques semaines plus tard à la sortie
de l'école ma mère est venue me chercher
avec une lettre entre les mains une
lettre du premier ministre qui m'avait
répondu et qui m'a encouragé à
persévérer dans mes engagements
toutes ces expériences
m'ont fait que décupler mon envie de
m'engager
mon proulx qui n'avait pas d'âge ou de
bons moments pour défendre des causes
qu'il ne fallait pas attendre pour
essayer de se faire entendre
et surtout que nos actions du quotidien
même une toute petite échelle celle
d'une classe de collège d'un email sous
d'une banque alimentaire ne sont jamais
vaine ou inutiles
pourtant les choses sérieusement
véritablement commencé que quelques
temps plus tard en juin 2010 est le 18
juin 2017 pour être précis
ce soir-là à 20 heures je suis devant ma
télé à bordeaux avec toute ma famille
pour regarder les résultats du second
tour des élections législatives
une super soirée
et comme tout le monde je découvre avec
effarement les chiffres gigantesques de
l'abstention
plus d'un jeune électeur sur deux n'est
pas allé voter pour élire son député
une première sous la vème république
et même si je sentais bien depuis
longtemps autour de moi parmi mes
camarades de classe mes amis ou défiance
vis-à-vis de la politique voire parfois
pire une forme d'indifférence
j'imaginais pas que la rupture était si
profond
pour moi ce soir là c'est un choc à tel
point que j'arrive pas m'endormir et que
je fini par appeler en face time au
milieu de la nuit deux de mes meilleurs
amis
augustin et dorothée pour leur pitch est
une idée un peu atypique
pourquoi on lancerait pas un nouveau
projet pour intéresser notre génération
à la politique
dès le lendemain matin quelques-uns à
peine de quoi remplir une table à se
retrouver autour d'un café à bordeaux
les idées fusent dans tous les sens et
c'est ainsi qu'est né dans un grand
brouhaha d'entousiasme sur un coin de
table et sur un coup de tête le premier
mouvement à partisans pour réconcilier
les jeunes avec le débat d'idées et avec
l'engagement citoyen
on était juste une poignée d'amis on
n'avait pas d'argent pas d'expérience
pas de réseau personne dans nos
entourages qui fâchent de la politique
et pour la plupart d'entre nous moi le
premier même pas le droit de vote on
avait envie et de l'énergie à revendre
je ne mesurais pas encore à l'époque
mais la première grande aventure
d'engagement de ma vie venait de
commencer
quatre ans plus tard le mouvement s'est
déployée dans plusieurs villes en france
on a organisé des centaines de débats et
conférences mobilisé des milliers de
jeunes reçu des élus de tous bords
politiques des artistes des
entrepreneurs des dirigeants associatifs
on a ouvert les portes des grandes
institutions le sénat l'assemblée
nationale des mairies à des jeunes de
tous les milieux
quatre années en tout cas
particulièrement intense
parfois décourageante quand je vois par
exemple que l'abstention augmente
élection après élection malgré tous nos
efforts pour ré intéresser les jeunes à
la politique
mais toujours passionnante et tellement
stimulante
parce que s'engager c'est apprendre sur
les autres et à prendre sur soi
s'engager c'est rencontrer des gens que
vous n'auriez jamais croisé dans votre
vie autrement
s'engager enfin c'est se poser la
question du sens que l'on veut donner à
nos vies
qu'est ce qui compte vraiment pour nous
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
reprendre une formule qu'on nous rabâche
souvent réussir sa vie
la plus d'entre vous avaient été
étudiant ou comme moi il est encore en
ce moment même
et qu'est ce qu'on nous a appris au
cours de nos études et sans doute en
fait inconsciemment depuis la maternelle
on nous a appris à être bon à l'école
avoir des bonnes de bonnes appréciations
à réussir des concours à viser les
meilleures écoles à être les meilleurs
tout simplement
mais à quel moment dans le parcours on
nous a dit
fais quelque chose qui a du sens pour
toi
il ya quelques mois
j'ai réalisé l'un des plus grands rêves
d'enfance
écrire et publier mon premier livre sur
l'engagement de la nouvelle génération
avec les namas coauteur nous sommes
partis à la rencontre de 18
personnalités essentiellement des jeunes
de tous les horizons un prof un
journaliste une dirigeante d'assaut en
avocat ministre et tous
absolument tous quels que soient leur
âge leur mais que leur métier leur vécu
ont un point commun
ils ont trouvé du sens dans ce qu'ils
font le truc qui les motive et les fait
avancer
et le s'épanouissent parce qu'ils ont
l'impression que ce qu'ils font est
utile fait avancer d'une manière ou
d'une autre la société a du sens
alors si je ne devais vous partagez
qu'un seul message il serait très simple
engagez vous
engagez vous au quotidien posez vous la
question du sens dans chacun de vos
projets
c'est un conseil que j'ai emprunté à ma
grand mère qui me disait toujours quand
tu te lance un défi demande toi pourquoi
et pour qui tu le fais
pour les autres ou pour toi par conte
forme isma habitude pression sociale
pour le titre sur linkedin ou parce que
ça correspond vraiment à tes aspirations
longtemps par exemple j'ai cru que le
diplôme était la seule voie pour réussir
bon élève j'ai pleinement joué le jeu du
système académique
avant de comprendre que ce sont d'abord
et avant tout mes convictions et mes
engagements qu'ils ne définissent
et ce qui est cool avec l'engagement
c'est qu'il ya plein de façons de se
lancer
dans l'assaut de votre école dans votre
club de sport dans votre entreprise et
oui même les entreprises peuvent être
engagées dans une grande rue lg ou dans
l'assaut du point de la rue ou même
tissé demain en lançant peut-être vos
propres projets
il ya mille et une façons de s'engager
et tout ce que je peux vous souhaitez à
chacune et chacun d'entre vous c'est
tout simplement de trouver la vôtre de
trouver votre moteur d'engagement
c'est un chemin difficile
plein de doutes de remise en question
mais j'en suis convaincu et au bout du
compte c'est le chemin du bonheur du
bonheur individuel bien sûr mais aussi
et surtout du bonheur collectif
j'appartiens comme beaucoup d'entre vous
dans cette salle a une génération née
après la chute du mur de berlin et
l'effondrement des grands mythes du
xxème siècle sans utopie ou idéologie
auquel a adhéré aveuglément
dans une société orpheline de ses
structures traditionnelles les églises
les partis les syndicats de plus en plus
délaissée par les jeunes
donc à une génération parfois tenté
c'est vrai par le repli sur soi
voire étrangement malgré l'apparent
connexion que nous promettait les
réseaux sociaux par la solitude
les héritiers de l'air due d pour
reprendre une formule du philosophe
gilles lipovetsky
mais
quoi que certains puissent en penser
j'appartiens au 6ème génération
incroyablement résiliente cas grandi
avec les attentats terroristes
le chômage de masse l'urgence climatique
une démocratie en crise et le manque de
perspective d'avenir
mais qui a soif de changement
d'indépendance de liberté et de progrès
génération la solitude
ou génération engagée
nous avons choix
bien sûr elle se serait sans doute le
plus facile nous pouvons faire le choix
du statu quo ne penser qu'à nos intérêts
propres à nos préoccupations
individuelles donner raison à tous ceux
et ils sont nombreux qui caricature
notre génération comme égoïste feignante
individualiste
mais nous pouvons aussi
faire un autre choix
celui de l'intérêt général au delà nos
intérêts individuels
nous pouvons faire le choix de
l'engagement
et je terminerai en vous partageant une
citation qui me tient à coeur c'est la
citation qui figure à la première page
de mon livre
cette citation c'est celle d'un écrivain
philosophe un intellectuel et
probablement en toute objectivité le
plus flamboyant des engagés
albert camus
cas mais nous dit on et en 1957 mais ça
n'a jamais été aussi vrai qu'aujourd'hui
camus nous dit
chaque génération sans doute se croit
voué à refaire le monde
la mienne sait pourtant qu'elle ne leur
fera pas
mais ça et peut-être plus grande encore
elle consiste à empêcher que le monde ne
se défasse je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]